Congressman Darren lahood of the house
Ways and Means Committee he's also a
former Federal prosecutor Congressman
just breaking moments ago from the Free
Beacon photos placed Hunter Biden at his
dad's house the day he invoked Joe's
name to that Chinese business partner
your response well Laura I think you
laid out well in your opening there the
intentional effort by doj to protect
Hunter Biden and if people want evidence
on that they ought to read these
transcripts I would tell your viewers go
online tonight they're online these are
top IRS investigators that have been on
this case for five plus years they have
been
at every level told The Stand Down by
the Department of Justice and if you
read their the the level of criminality
that is alleged by these whistleblowers
is mind-blowing and and by the way these
aren't Republicans saying this these are
whistleblowers at the highest level
involved that did this and let's
remember what happened here eight
million dollars Hunter Biden got from
Ukraine China and Romania didn't pay
taxes on it and then also there's this
rush to do a plea agreement when we're
going to have the transcripts uh
revealed today they wanted that play
agreement out they wanted that out
before these transcripts were out
correct absolutely they've been working
on this for five and a half years
suddenly on Monday morning when it gets
announced that we're going to release
those today that happens there's no
coincidence in that Laura what happened
and so to your point earlier the set the
the acceptance of The Plea will happen
on July 26 in Wilmington Delaware by the
federal judge that judge has the
opportunity through the discretion that
judge to not accept this point what are
the grounds for rejecting a plea deal
usually it's it's unusual it's unusual
reject the plea deal it's obviously
fraud in the inducement if someone was
fraudulently induced to make the plea
deal I know that's one grounds what
grounds do you think here would apply I
think if you read what's alleged by
these whistleblowers that I don't think
was before the doj or the um or Weiss
when he entered into this agreement I
think any judge that looks at that and
then looks at the conduct that's in here
this is a slap on the wrist I think
about my constituents Laura if they
didn't pay taxes on eight million
dollars and and had uh all and and was
involved with Russia and Ukraine and
Romania it wouldn't be a misdemeanor so
it's hard to believe that an expungeable
gun charge and two misdemeanors is what
Hunter Biden gets it's an intentional
protection by the doj now I want to
remind everyone what Merrick Garland
said under oath this was back in March
watch this the the U.S attorney in
Delaware has been advised that he has
full authority to bring cases in other
jurisdictions he is not to be denied
anything that he needs I have pledged
not to interfere uh with that
investigation and I have carried through
on my pledge
whistleblower revealed that this was
this was true he says that in October 7
2022 the Biden appointed a c u s
attorney Matthew Graves would not allow
the Delaware U.S attorney to charge
hunter in his district and he asked for
special counsel Authority from Maine doj
at that time
but was denied
Congressman did Garland
commit perjury there come close I I
think we got to find out that's very
disturbing and contradictory to
everything that's in these whistleblower
what motivation with these
whistleblowers and as you pointed out
during the during before the show
Democrats you used to love
whistleblowers right but what what
motivation would they have to just what
make all this up so much fun no I mean
we asked them questions about anything
related there is no motivation here in
fact they've been um you know they the
doj has gone after them for coming
forward on this the other thing to think
about here in my time as a federal
prosecutor doj No One lets the statue of
limitations run out on these tax charges
they purposely slow walk this so the
statute of the limitations yeah I mean
so I mean everything everyone is obvious
it's almost embarrassing I mean it's but
hunter was so careless in these messages
he's just a dope sorry I mean he's like
proud of myself I'm sure he's proud of
us but he was so it was so obvious what
was going on in those messages they were
shaking down the Chinese and the Chinese
wanted influence they weren't looking
for his business expertise or his Acumen
because he has none but he has the last
name Biden and that's all that China
wanted again intentional protection by
the doj of Hunter Biden because he was
President Biden's son that's the bottom
line and if you don't believe
Republicans on that read the transcripts
everyone we're going to link them on
Instagram and Twitter Congressman thank
you for being in studio tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else